let's do one more critical rendering
path diagram but this time I want you to
create the diagram for a real website if
you have your own site I want you to
analyze that and if you don't you can
analyze any site you want but be careful
lots of sites especially the large ones
have long and complicated critical
rendering path
I recommend analyzing a simple or a
static page I've included a couple of
links and instructor notes for you to
try cool and let me guess you want us to
post our diagrams on the forums uh-huh
along with the three CRP metrics you got
it and don't forget to tell us what page
you're actually analyzing that sounds
like fun I can't wait to start comparing
CRP diagrams for all kinds of websites
yeah this will be a fun exercise also in
addition to analyzing your own site take
a look at what other students have found
and provide feedback good luck